- Today we are celebrating
the 20th season of The Voice!
I'm here with coaches Blake Shelton,
Nick Jonas and John Legend.
(Kelly mimics air horn)
(audience cheers)
So it was recently announced, Nick,
that Ariana is now coming in.
She's gonna take your seat next season.
So here's the reason why I ask.
- What?
- Wait a minute!
- Exactly!
It's just this season.
So like, here's my question, though.
Do you have any advice for her?
- No, I mean, Ariana as we all know
is one of the best singers in the game,
and she's gonna be an incredible coach.
I think the only advice I would give,
is just not to trust any one of you.
(Kelly laughs)
- Why?
- We've been feeding her
lots of useful advice.
- Yeah, I'm sure. Very useful.
- [Kelly] Totally! Yeah.
But she's gonna kill it. She'll be great.
- Yeah. I thought, yeah, you
can at least warn her about
the one she's probably gonna sit next to.
Might be nice.
- [Nick] All of you.
- She watches the show, though. She knows.
- [Nick] She does.
- She knows about Blake.
- [Kelly] She does watch the show!
- What does that mean? What do you mean?
- Everybody knows about
Blake. Everybody knows.
- Lies and deception.
- I just hope I don't step on her.
Look at her! She looks so tiny on there.
(Kelly and John laugh)
- She's so tiny, I know.
- The height differential
between the two of you
will be substantial.
- [Blake] Wow.
- I really hope she's
sitting right next to you.
It'll just look amazing.
(Kelly and John laugh)
So wait. Are y'all scared of Ariana?
- Uh yes.
- I am too! (John laughs)
I'm terrified.
Somebody literally asked us
the interviews yesterday.
We were going together and they said
"What do you think about Ariana?"
I was like, "I think this
is my last chance to win".
(John laughs) I was like,
"That's what I think!"
- Ariana has a huge fan base.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
And they are fervent.
And if they show up to
vote, we're all in trouble.
- 100%.
(John laughs)
Are you scared at all?
- No.
- [Kelly] Would you even tell us?
- I'm not afraid of her fan base.
Where are they at? Look
at me! Where's the camera.
Bring it, Arianna fans! Bring it on!
I'm not afraid of all y'all.
(John laughs)
They pay me to win.
- Oh my gosh.
- Ya hear that?
Ariana fans. Is that you guys?
Are y'all Arianna fans?
(John laughs)
See how silent you are?
(Kelly and John laugh)
- Okay. Well, speaking of scared,
I saw you just had an
incident with a possum.
What happened?
- What'd you say? I had an incident?
- [Kelly] You had an
incident with a possum.
- Incident with a possum. Yeah.
- They should've sat you next to me!
So you can hear me!
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I did.
I was at the house in
Oklahoma, and I was just,
I was there by myself, and
I just grilled something
on the grill, and I got it out.
I was letting it cool off
and I went back to get it,
and it was a damn possum over there.
Look! Eating my, I
actually grilled some fish.
- [John] Oh my God!
- [Blake] I was like, "Hey man!"
- [Kelly] I didn't actually
see this whole thing!
They told me. Wait!
- [John] I didn't know he ate the food!
- Yeah! He was in my food.
- Oh!
- Later I got, I don't know
if y'all have the video,
I ended up petting it
and hanging out with it.
- [John] Were you grilling a possum?
- [Blake] There it is! There
I am petting it. (John laughs)
I wasn't grilling a possum.
Look at it. He likes me!
- [Kelly] Real quick question.
Have you ever heard of rabies?
- [Nick] Yeah.
- Oh ho ho.
Well you're probably not
gonna air the next video.
- [Kelly] Well, no, my point.
- No, I'm just kidding!
- Oh, what?
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I had nothing left to
eat, he ate my food so.
- Oh my gosh!
- No. I let him to it.
- So John, have you ever
encountered a wild animal?
- Well, the scariest time we were in
Tanzania.
- Ooh. I've never done that!
- East Africa.
And a black mamba.
- Whoa.
- [John] Which is a snake.
- Which I know. Which is deadly.
- And is deadly.
I did not see this
black mamba,
but everyone who was
with me saw it near me,
and I had, didn't see it.
I was walking the other way,
but I was close enough to it
that it could've bitten me,
but I escaped it.
And then everyone was like,
"John, did you just see that black mamba?"
And I completely missed
it, but apparently.
- That's probably why you
didn't get bit, though.
'Cause you didn't freak out.
- Yeah. Well I didn't notice it.
- That's what I'm
saying. You were so calm.
- And so it was right there, though.
It could have gotten me.
- [Kelly] Dang!
- Yeah.
- That is wild.
- Cause I've Been on one of the safaris.
I think they just carry a gun in case.
They don't carry like, you know,
something to save your life
if you get bit by snake. (John laughs)
Like, wow! That's scary!
- Yes!
- Yeah.
- So, I didn't know to be scared or not,
'cause I didn't actually see it,
but everyone around me
was very scared for me.
- Oh my God. I'd've freaked out.
Have you? Have you ever had
anything crazy, like animal?
- I have, yeah. Not as scary as that.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- But I got chased by
a pack of coyotes once.
- [All] What?!
- Come on.
- I swear to God!
- A pack?
- You Jonas boys. Every of
you tell crap like that.
(all laugh)
- Wait, what do you mean?
Like a pack of coyotes?
That's dangerous!
- Yeah so, I was just coming
out of a movie theater.
- This is in Los Angeles?
- This is in Los Angeles.
And
I step outside and start
walking by myself, walking home.
My friend's like, "We'll give you a ride."
I was like, "I wanna get some fresh air."
And so, I'm walking.
And then I see these eyes in the dark.
And then I see about
six more sets of eyes.
- They just wanted an autograph.
- They take off running after me.
- [Kelly] That's terrifying.
- So I go full sprint, like
this, about half a mile
to my house, jumped the fence,
and they're all at the fence.
And they don't chase people normally.
They do in a pack, though. They will.
- Oh my God.
- So it was quite frightening.
I should mention that when
I was getting the fresh air,
I may have (Nick puffs air)
you know, a little bit.
- Giving the aroma to be attracted too.
- Got it. Got it.
- Okay. Okay. So wait. So wait.
- So this may or may not have happened.
- So really what chased you
are a bunch of maltipoos?
(Kelly laughs)
- Are you saying Coyotes are
attracted to the smell of?
- You had like a bunch of
Beverly Hills Chihuahuas
chasing you like it's a
wild, rabid, pack of dogs.
- Yeah, so. No one else was with me.
I can't be sure that is what happened.
- Oh my God.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] My God!
- You lost me at fresh air
in Los Angeles, anyway.
(John laughs)
- Lies and deception. Agreed.
So before we go to break,
I want to talk about
something that happened
earlier this season.
The date was October 19th, 2020.
I graciously invited
Blake to be on my show
to promote his vodka.
Not only did he forget his Team
Kelly jacket, this happened.
- Because I've noticed over
the years that you play
a lot of games.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Even outside of this show.
- [Kelly] I do.
- Like you're a gamer.
- I'm a winner as well.
- A winner? Exactly right.
Which maybe,
maybe this gift, well,
goes against that idea that
you're a winner all the time.
- Oh. So it's a lie.
- This is a gift that represents,
- [Kelly] Lies.
- Every person who has
beaten you on your show
with the podium that I gave you.
(guitar plays)
- Wait a minute! All
these people have beat me?
- I've never missed an
episode of your show.
(Kelly laughs)
And I wrote down every single
time somebody has beaten you.
(audience cheers)
- I hate that wall!
There are now, whatever,
17 photos up there,
including Blake's.